i think this winter's going to be  frightening  um i live alone um i've got a plan with  a friend who also lives alone if we need  to we'll go  half time in each other's houses leaving  one house cold for a week  and then spending the time back in the  house to warm it up again  and having to do things like that  i'm a nurse and i used to see people  come in old people  hungry and cold in the winter  malnourished and i think i'm going to  see it again  when i think about 90 year olds coming  in who've been laid on the floor for  three days  who have only got yoghurt in the fridge  the fact is that in intensive care if  they've been if they've done that they  won't come in alive there'll be a  90-yard who froze to death in their home  how does that make you feel  it's appalling it's appalling when they  come in alive on the brink of  on the brink of death  it'll be appalling if we don't get them  in because they're already dead on the  floor those poor paramedics  and those poor people